we are building the most technologically
advanced the most beautiful cruise ships
ever what the Disney wish is the first
of its kind never been done before
[Music]
so how do you build a Disney wish it's a
first in-class ship so you start with a
white piece of paper
the construction phase is always one of
the most amazing phases because you can
see things come to life the Disney wish
is the first of its kind it's a very
iterative process design engineering
together with interior designers takes a
good year and a half so approximately
one and a half to two years in already
we will then actually cut the first
piece of Steel
off we go and then there is no stopping
it
they actually subdivide the entire
shipping blocks those blocks are
subdivided in sections and each section
is unique this is block 73 the main
Bridge of our ship where the captain
will navigate the ship they build like
in a car manufacturing but instead of
having all the same cars these are all
unique sections but built in the same
way it's mind-blowing when you see it
for the first time that's pretty
spectacular the ship has more than 100
blocks typically a block would be the
full width of a ship and usually three
to four decks High more than 100 of
those creates the entire ship
the ship is really really big the ship
will be more than 60 million kilograms
close to 150 million pounds they're 1.2
million square feet
almost three football fields long just
the technical aspect of that is
mind-blowing
it floats
I know someone did a lot of math but I
still don't understand how it floats but
it floats how does the ship float our
communist principle says that an object
and its volume will displace water
weight of water that displaces needs to
be at least the weight of that object
let's think of a golf ball that's quite
dense and heavy when you put that in the
water it will displace water it will
sink if you take a soccer ball a lot of
air inside so it's not very dense that
will also displace some water but only
its own weight we all know it will float
a cruise ship is quite large and a lot
of volume inside empty spaces it
actually only displaces a little bit of
water and stays above the water I cannot
believe it's actually happening like
pinching myself unbelievable it's going
so fast now
there's these three pieces of ship being
built the four ship in the AFT and then
the midship which we call the Giga block
that gigabrook will actually go inside
the hole then get connected to our four
ship this blows me away because quite
practically this is a skyscraper
floating towards us it's crazy
while they're building the ship they're
also building the staterooms when the
shipyard builds like this they can do a
lot of pre-out fitting that's what it's
all about check it out look at this one
completed prefabricated Stadium it's
ramping up very quickly to our Disney
wish getting completed and coming out of
the hall in all our Glory
foreign
[Music]